when someone like Scarlett Johansson is
cast as the lead in an adaptation of a
Japanese comic franchise it's important
to understand that the ensuing anger
isn't just about that movie and it's not
just about Tilda Swinton playing a
Tibetan character in Marvel's Doctor
Strange or Emma Stone claiming to be
part Chinese in Hawaiian in Aloha my dad
was half chinese half wine and my mother
is Swedish it's how all these casting
decisions combined dating back to the
earliest days of Hollywood have made
Asians invisible at best and at worst
the butt of a cruel joke that's why fans
notice when the characters from The Last
Airbender cartoon become much lighter
skinned for the live-action movie and
when John Rico goes from being Filipino
in the novel starship troopers to being
played by someone named Casper Van Dien
I want to try it again but this time we
need you to do an accent the fact is
things aren't getting better fast enough
for Asians in Hollywood in 1944 Alan
McMahon was nominated for an Oscar for
her yellow face role in Dragon's seed
later on Linda hunt would win an Oscar
for playing a Chinese man in the year of
living dangerously but in a quad that
was 1982 almost 40 years later basically
everything else in the country had
changed except white people being cast
as Asians for a solid two decades the
Chinese detective character Charlie Chan
was played by white men in makeup but
that was the 30s and 40s right well
here's Jim Sturgess
and Hugo Weaving reincarnated as Koreans
for parts of Cloud Atlas
everyone remembers Mickey Rooney's
infamous 1961 performance and breakfast
at tiffany's as just fully unacceptable
and racist right well 24 years later
Joel gray delivered this Korean
caricature in Remo Williams I think I
can't do such and another two decades
later here's Rob Schneider and I now
pronounce you chuck and Larry how the
Ling's are a symbol of eternity
Nider is a quarter Filipino so progress
or how about Peter Sellers 1968 role as
a clueless Indian man at a dinner party
for 20 years later Fisher Stevens was in
brown face for short circuit two and
another 24 years after that Ashton
Kutcher is doing this in a popchips
commercial arguably worse than white
people playing Asian characters is white
people playing real-life Asian humans
which is what happened to Cora lijek in
Argo and to Geoffrey ma who appeared in
the movie 21 as this character even
though in real life he was this guy it's
not surprising that directors want to
hire big names to attract producers and
funding but when they want to do stories
about Asians and won't cast Asian actors
they should know that the blowback
against that has been building for the
better part of a century one of the
early examples of a white cast playing
Asian characters was the good earth in
1937 based on hugely popular novel by
pearl s buck
there was an Asian actress who wanted
the lead part her name was Anna May Wong
and she was basically the only Chinese
American movie star at the time one of
the reasons that MGM reportedly snubbed
her was that in the 30s and 40s
Hollywood was censored
a moral code and it prohibited things
like nudity and profanity but also
interracial romance so once they cast a
white man to play Wang Lung they
couldn't cast Wang to play his wife the
role went to a german-born actress named
Lewis Rayner and she went on to win an
Oscar for it